Naomi zhan Luis has been living in this
shelter for weeks she was forced to
leave her home when battles between
rival gangs took over her neighborhood
in Port-au-Prince
I'm a disabled person and I'm the father
and mother of children the situation I'm
living in isn't good at all even to go
to the doctor's office I have to go and
ask in the street because of the
insecurity
Naomi is among thousands of people who
have been displaced by the Raging
violence across much of Haiti this is
part of the ongoing chaos that has
gripped the country ever since
presidential venel mois was killed last
year
despite dozens of arrests including a
group of Colombian mercenaries Haiti's
investigation has told
the acting prime minister Adel Enrique
fired his Justice Minister and
prosecutor last year when they called
for him to be investigated in connection
with Moises murder Henry has denied any
involvement in the killing trying the
assassination and assassin the president
is a very difficult thing in any country
in any country it's it's major this is
this is really bad but in Haiti the
situation that we have this is a country
really all of our institutions have not
been functional even under the on the
job now the the justice system
everything the police everything is just
not functional a parallel investigation
in the U.S has three suspects in custody
including a former U.S government
informant who pleaded not guilty on
Wednesday and faces life in prison if
convicted the U.S Department of Justice
wants to seal evidence of past Crimes by
some of the suspects many who are also
informants
even though Ariel enri took over the
Office of Prime Minister and enjoys the
support of Western Powers Haitian Civil
Society groups questioned his authority
and are approaching for a transition
that will lead to elections that have
been repeatedly delayed for five years
Haitians are facing an economic crisis
that was only made worse by the pandemic
and the war in Ukraine
half of the country struggling with food
insecurity and Rising inflation is
making life harder for everyone
like thousands of others in search of a
better life someplace else and Juan
Guerrero was forced back to Haiti after
being deported from the United States
moving we are imprisoned in our own
country because the insecurity makes
every single person have a single goal
which is to leave this country the
reason why it is uninhabitable I feel
like leaving this country again because
the situation is very complicated so
complicated that more Haitians than any
time in recent memory are risking
everything to escape
believing the situation in their home
country will not improve any time soon
foreign